let's start by rehearsing what's the
definition
of this expansion using our binomial
coefficients using our ncr and that kind
of thing
okay the first term the first term
right if i've got a as um the first time
the binomial v is a second right
it's going to be a to the n but how many
lots
of a to the n are there i think back to
pascal's triangle
and how we rewrote it it's going to be
n choose zero right
it's always going to be n true zero
because um you start off by saying
i mean this coefficient has to be uh one
right and so it's going to be how many
ways can i choose
zero out of n because otherwise it'd be
you know a bigger number
okay now when you go to the next one
what you've got is n choose one
so that just increments up okay your
power of n
is going to drop down one right and your
power of b
will increase and really actually
there's a bead of zero hiding there
which is just one
and then the trend continues
okay does that make sense now how does
it finish off because this is um
this is a finite series right
um hence the finance series where does
anders let's do the second last term
okay it's still going to be n choose but
what am i going to be up to if i'm at
the second last term
n minus 1 right which by the way is the
same as
n choose one do you remember that um
equidistant relationship we looked at
yesterday
what are we gonna have here how many
lots of a will we have
this is the second last term so just the
one right
and we'll have n minus one lots of b and
then our very last term
and choose and all the a's are gone and
you're just left with
b okay great so far so good
now the most useful or one of the most
useful kinds of
a and b it's kind of an interesting
simple combination
it's treating the a as one and the b as
x okay now
that might seem kind of arbitrary to you
and also why don't we put the x
first um or v reveal so hold on
how does this expand though okay let's
think about this
these coefficients are all going to be
the same okay because what the
coefficients come from is just the power
right so i'm going to have and choose
not i'm going to have
n choose one and choose two and so on
okay what am i going to have as the um
the other parts of the term apart from
the coefficient
well here i have 1 to the power of n
right and no lots of x
this next one here is going to be one to
the power of n minus one
and how many lots of x we've got one
this time
right plus this will be one of the minus
two two lines of x and so on and all the
way up onto the end
okay so this is going to be the same
coefficient
one lot of one that many lot of x's
and then the very last term
no lots of one and that many lots of x
okay
now i wonder if you can see why we put
the x second rather than first even
though so far from the x first
because what this is or the one to the
power of whatever okay
they're all just one yes so i can
actually get rid of all the ones
from out of this series okay so this is
n choose zero
plus n choose one i don't need to put
the one there because it's redundant
really
lots of x n choose 2
lots of x squared i might just stick in
another one just for the sake of it n
choose 3 lots of x
cubed and you can see that
this term down the bottom of the ncr
right the r
that corresponds to the power of x that
you've got right can you see that
okay so the reason why i put the x
second is because what i get at the end
now um this series here that's the way
we ordinarily write
gps right this is gp okay
all right now fire that away in the back
of your mind
and you may like to get out either this
sheet
oops and how do you look at the bottom
of the page there's a whole bunch of
things with sigma notation and also i'm
going to do
two or maybe three depending on how time
goes of the questions out of the program
which introduces
notation this line here right this line
because it's just a gp okay this is
prime material for writing it in sigma
notation okay
so the first thing i'd say is how many
terms are there in this series
i started at zero and i ended at n
okay so they're n plus one terms the way
that i would count that up is i'd say
from
let's start from zero because that's my
first one and then i'll go up to
m because that'll be my last one okay
now what's the what's the thing that
goes in here what's the function that
actually gets
evaluated as the thing goes up
well as r increments i'm going to have n
choose
r right so i start zero one two three
and so on
okay but then i also have this x term to
deal with
okay it's x to the power of
r right this number and this number
always match up
exactly okay that's how i built the
series okay so this here
might stick in color
this is a crucial identity to get okay
um it's a really nice i mean this is why
it's it's handy that we learned sigma
notation under series and sequences
because it's way better like this than
this previous line okay
right now let's go to the program and
see how um there are some examples of
how we actually use this
so i think this is um under 0.7
in the program it says prove finite
series that's where the name comes from
and given this result so this is a this
is a given you can quote that okay
let's prove this this is the first one
what you're required to prove is
r equals zero all the way up to m
of this is that
okay so just have a look at it first
now if i hadn't told you any of this
before and even
having told you when you look at this
the first time
thinking about it as an identity we tend
to
go from you know when you get left hand
side right hand side you think
start from the complex side and then go
to the simpler side
right does that make sense because our
brains tend to simplify better they
make things more complicated okay so
instinctively you go from this side
to this side right probably okay
because this is a whole bunch of things
and we would probably expect that in
some way you're going to simplify out
and it will come down to this okay i'll
just save you 15 minutes now
it won't okay not unless unless you're
aware of this
okay so in fact i'm going to start
with the right hand side that's a bit
counter to you isn't it i wonder if
you're if the cogs are turning you can
see the relationship to what we
just established up here start at the
right hand side
which is 2 to the n okay now how can i
relate this
to this result we've just shown which
does it look more like
it looks more like this side right in
the special case where
x is equal to one right so what i've got
here this is one plus one
to the power of n right and so now you
can see where the binomial expansion
comes in right
because this here is a um a proven
result
i can say that's equal to r
true sorry r equals zero up to n of n
choose r now x to the power of r
is really 1 to the power of r because
i've chosen
x equals 1 in this case okay so 1
to the power of r even though again it's
trivial it's important that you
include it so you show you understand
where this came from okay
and from there well that's basically it
isn't it
that's all i was asked to prove okay so
that's not true dramatic right
okay